if it's okay i'd like to talk for just a
second about the top of these
shows when i say these shows i mean
these talk shows there are a lot of them
now and as you know a lot of hosts they
come out
and they start the show by telling some
monologue jokes
okay and that's fine for them and hey i
did it for a long time too
all right but i like to innovate i like
to change things up
okay so i'm sorry other hosts all right
i hate to rock the boat but what i like
to do
is uh innovate a little bit i'm not
scared of that word
what i've done is i've found a way to
tell great topical jokes
that adds excitement and sex appeal at
the same time
you get your topical jokes but then i
put a little
spice at the end yeah you're gonna like
this
check it out here we go hey
it uh turns out that construction of
trump's border wall might continue
under president biden yeah and just to
be dicks
mexico offered to pay for it
can you feel the earth is shaking it's a
conan comedy quake
doesn't matter what the subject conan's
got the best steak
uh okay um why are you doing this again
i'm speaking truth to power andy that's
what brave comics do
okay geez due to a mask dispute
a new jersey family was temporarily
kicked off a spirit airlines flight
yeah as punishment the family was let
back on the plane
and forced to fly on spirit airlines
that was like a supernova probably was
seen from space
or because a perfect joke left this
perfect
fairy ace
yes you really want to use the word
perfect
yeah okay what i'm telling you
i'm taking out the little guy taking on
the big guy
and that takes bravery okay and sex
appeal
hey critics are pointing out that it
took joe biden 65 days before he had his
first press conference
when asked about it a white house
spokesperson said we didn't want to wake
him
couldn't escape inviting honest no
malarkey on his watch
he's got fire in his eyes and on his
crotch
yuck that no we don't need to
what we don't need to know you don't
have to have somebody hire someone to
sing about your pubes
okay i don't listen to the lyrics i just
know this looks
awesome and i assume the lyrics are
appropriate okay
caitlyn jenner said she might run for
governor of california
and then lose badly
holy crap what a wordsmith he can turn a
phrase so good
our hearts and minds are starving and
commands jokes are food
i just i think you're better than this
well guess what i'm not
okay burn hey it's come out
that matt gates asked then-president
trump for a blanket pardon to cover any
of his crimes
yeah given the age of his dates he
should have asked for a
blankie pardon
make sure you have flood insurance after
that joke tsunami
good thing i'm a geico agent wanna quote
ask me hey here's a quote uh this bit
could have been a lot shorter
you just described our show for 2018 i
guess okay
now you've come to that conclusion
that's a fair point
it's a waste of andy's time now he's got
better things to do
he needs to get right back on foot
number two
you